cher get in here what's up daddy what
the hell is that
a dress says who calvin klein it looks
like underwear
no monet's here up close this clueless
recreation is perfection
cher's a very happy girl she's happy
happy happy happy alycia silverstone
celebrated the iconic movie's 26th
anniversary on monday
we're going very very overboard here
cher horowitz herself has been all about
sharing tributes to the beloved
character
oh get off of me
[Applause]
when alicia joined tick tock last month
she enlisted her 11 year old son
bear for this reenactment
[Music]
now the mother sun scene partners are at
it again to celebrate the anniversary
cher get in here what's up daddy what
the hell is that
a dress says who calvin klein
it looks like underwear alicia shared
their newest recreation to her instagram
with bear stepping into the role of
cher's dad uptight lawyer
mel cher get in here what's up daddy
what the hell is that
a dress says who calvin klein
it looks like underwear last year alicia
told et about the first time her son
watched the cherished 90s hit
i don't know how many of your other
movies he's seen if anything like when
will he watch clueless
no you know what i made the oopsy
doopsies i let him watch clueless
because
clueless was on they had it at the
cemetery
and there were 4 000 people watching it
together and i went to present it and i
thought this is one of those
opportunities where i don't know where
he'll get to see
this experience again so i did invite
him and we laid into the stars
on a blanket and pillows watching the
movie together and it was divine
i would not have chosen for him to see
it that early
um that was a that was a special thing
it really is like
i mean just wild to me how much people
still quote that movie
when people come up to you what do they
say to you the most and and maybe what's
your all-time favorite line
i love when well it's not my line but i
love
when britney murphy says you're a virgin
who can't
drive you're a virgin
who can't drive i like oops
watch out for the bike
in my life sometimes for fun to make
myself laugh i'll say oops my bad
because you know there are things that
you do and you go well
you